one of the coolest things in the wind
tunnel is to see water floating
it poured from a jug it quickly breaks
up into droplets the same size as
raindrops from around 0.5 to 4
millimeters in diameter and standing
there you can experience what it would
be like to fall with raindrops
they have a low terminal velocity of
just 25 kilometers per hour and that's
what the wind speed was set to for this
demonstration and what you can see is
that raindrops aren't shaped like
cartoon raindrops they are closer to
spherical but a bit flatter on the
bottom where they encounter oncoming air
if a raindrop gets too big it flattens
out caves in in the middle and briefly
resembles a little parachute before
breaking up into smaller droplets